Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new venom 2 video Sony just
made some big announcements about the
movie we got a bunch of details we found
out what the title is we know more about
the spider-man crossover of it all so
we'll break it all down if you're new to
my channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're doing an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
venom spider-man crossover moment in the
video so just going down the list here
starting with number 5 if you didn't see
the news this morning Sony officially
announced they delayed the movie to next
June which does suck nobody wants movies
to be delayed but it totally fixes some
of their other problems with the
spider-man crossover timeline process in
the way they had originally planned on
working Tom Hollands spider-man in all
the sinister six Easter eggs into the
venom movies in Marvel's spider-man 3
movie over in the MCU you have all these
people trying to explain how the venom
movies can crossover with the MCU but
somehow not be in the MCU so it gets
kind of complicated they had a plan but
then all these scheduling changes mess
that up a little bit now they fixed it
again you may have also noticed that
they waited to delay the venom movie
till after Warner Brothers delayed the
Batman movie next year because venom 2
basically took the Batman's original
release date in June next year they
didn't need to delay venom 2 that much
they only needed a little bit more time
to finish filming the movie and special
effects so they could have released it
in December if they wanted but Sony is
just really really thirsty for those big
summer movie release dates they're just
stuck on the idea that there's only a
couple weekends a year when they're big
spider-man movies can earn money the
other reason is they're also trying to
avoid overlapping too much with the
regular MCU Marvel movies that are
coming out early next year and in the
spring so you have all these comic book
movies all these spider-man movies
coming out in the first half of next
year my assumption now is that they'll
wait to release the venom 2 trailer till
later this summer or possibly towards
the end of the year but if I have any
news about that or they do drop any
footage or teasers of course I'll do a
video about that so number 4 sony also
just revealed the official title for
venom 2 and it's not maximum carnage
like a lot of us thought that it might
be they're calling it venom let there be
carnage which isn't exactly a banger
that's not my favorite title ever
but I think it just confirms that
they're saving the maximum carnage title
for the big full-blown spider-man venom
crossover movie that's happening later
after spider-man 3 because if you not a
big comic book reader the maximum
carnage story was primarily a spider-man
story told from Peter Parker's
perspective so maximum carnage was more
like spider-man versus carnage with
spider-man putting a team together and
then carnage putting a team together and
venom just helps spider-man out but they
didn't do maximum carnage till after the
first few carnage origin story issues
within the spider-man comics there was
originally a venom spider-man team-up to
fight carnage before maximum carnage
so quick backstory on that Eddie Brock
venom had been defeated by spider-man in
an earlier fight thrown in Rikers prison
in New York City his cellmate was Cletus
Kasady
the Venom symbiote comes to bust Eddie
out of prison and in the process spawned
an offspring symbiote without realizing
it
the symbiote just bonded to the nearest
person who happened to be Cletus Kasady
he went on a small rampage also breaking
out of prison spider-man had a mini
team-up with venom to stop him and they
used their old sonic weapons trick the
spider-man learned back when he was
using the church bells to get rid of the
symbiote back in the day Cletus Kasady
gets taken to the Ravencroft Institute
for psychological study while he's there
he changes back into carnage breaks out
again
and that sets off the events of maximum
carnage that became a much bigger Marvel
comic book crossover event with other
super villains and superheroes taking
sides it would be something more akin to
Sony during their own version of Captain
America Civil War but just with
spider-man characters so 3 what is the
new venom morbius spider-man crossover
timeline so Morbius is coming out in
March next year now we saw the Morbius
trailer they're clearly trying to
establish the spider-man exists in their
universe this is happening in New York
City this scene right here with the
graffiti I know it's a little confusing
with the Tobey Maguire spider-man suit
that's supposed to change to the Tom
Holland suit by the time the movie comes
out they're trying to imply that Tom
Hollands spider-man exists in the same
universe where this Morbius movie is
taking place we also saw that they're
setting up the sinister six movie as we
saw with the vulture scene of him
breaking out of prison thank you very
much Morbius for the assist it's on our
little spider friend I've got some boys
on the outside who love to meet him you
know take a picture slice his throat but
his head in a dryer and I heard a rumor
you know is spider-man's name is Peter
Parker
they were also supposed to be using this
prison breakout scene to explain how
Cletus Kasady predicts out of that
prison even though he doesn't appear in
this Morbius trailer the prison that
they're all breaking out up in this
scene is supposed to be the same prison
from the end of the venom movie that's
San Quentin in California the Scorpion
is also supposed to be in there too
somewhere so that sets off the beginning
of venom let there be carnage as the
movie is now called the story of what
happens when he breaks out of prison and
as he says in the first venom
post-credits scene causes a bunch of
carnage and in the process of that gets
bonded to the carnage symbiote it sounds
like the origin story for the carnage
symbiote will be relatively close to the
comic book explanation the Venom
symbiote spawns Eddie has no idea that's
even possible so he's not even paying
attention and then the symbiote becomes
bonded to Cletus Kasady who just happens
to be nearby
we saw them filming some scenes earlier
this year of Cletus Kasady stalking
Eddie Brock outside his San Francisco
apartment wearing that red and yellow
Hawaiian shirt so it sounds like Cletus
just starts coming for Eddie after he
escapes out of prison and that would
explain how he's nearby when the Venom
symbiote might spawn the carnage
symbiote they were also filming a lot of
big Church scenes so I'm wondering if
they're going to bring some of that
original spider-man venom origin story
from the church with the bells into the
venom 2 movie this actress is playing
shriek in the movie she's also a maximum
carnage comic-book character that teams
up with carnage it inevitably sounds
that venom will defeat carnage by the
end of the movie at least temporarily
then number two there's some sort of Tom
Holland post-credit scenes spider-man
cameo just setting up venom spider-man
maximum carnage crossover here's the
thing though venom two coming out in
June spider-man 3 is still coming out in
July just a month later
even though venom isn't supposed to be
in spider-man 3 that's mostly the story
of spider-man clearing his name proving
to everyone that Mysterio lied about
what happened in preventing whatever new
sinister six villain they introduced
from hunting him down quote-unquote now
that everyone knows his secret identity
spider-man John wick 3 with everyone
coming for him open season on spider-man
I did a video about this a little while
ago but it was also reported that Amy
Pascal revealed the spider-man 3 would
have home in the title like the other
two spider-man movies so post
all your spider-man 3 title theories in
the comments it's always possible
there's some kind of venom post-credit
scene at the end of that that also
teases future crossover but as far as
Kevin Feige has said all the venom
spider-man crossover stuff is totally
just a Sony thing so I think that just
implies that you'll see more of Tom
Holland in the venom movies then venom
showing up an MCU spider-man movies in
number one WTF because Sony is saving
the maximum carnage title for a later
movie when they do their full-blown
spider-man venom crossover inevitably
they just do that as maximum carnage in
the style of a Captain America Civil War
battle lines being drawn scenario just
imagine the airport battle if it were
all spider-man characters on both sides
although I don't think that Sony is
going to go quite as big as the MC use
version of Captain America Civil War
underoos
nice job kid well I could have stuck the
landing a little better it's just a new
suit what it's nothing mr. stark it's
perfect thank you yeah we don't really
need to start a conversation okay Kat
captain big fan spider-man I'm using
Captain America civil boards the
comparison because Avengers infinity war
was an Infinity Gauntlet story with a
nose snapping half of all life in the
universe and unless carnage were to get
a new Infinity Gauntlet the story of
that movie wouldn't be nearly as big in
scope as infinity war endgame maybe if
Sony could ever do a live-action
spider-man into the spider-verse
that would be more akin to a giant
infinity war level story or if they did
know the god of the symbiotes so
everyone just post all your reactions to
this in the comments below what do you
think about the venom 2 title and do you
think that they'll ever be able to work
up to a giant no god of the symbiotes
storyline Marvel actually just capped
off a giant venom comic book storyline
that got super cosmic where you
basically have venom saving the entire
universe it would be crazy if they could
ever pull that off in a movie imagine
what it would look like if venom
rebooted the entire universe it would be
crazy but that feels like too much of a
copy of Avengers endgame I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post a new Marvel
video there's a couple of the really big
things that just dropped in the past
couple of days so I'll try to post those
videos as soon as possible but leave all
your spider-man Marvel video requests in
the comments below
everyone click here for that venom 2
teaser trailer and click here for my
brand-new guardians of the galaxy 3
Marvel video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!